well dozens of women who are current or
former colleagues of Tom Brokaw are
circulating a letter in support of the
former NBC Nightly News anchor following
accusations by two women who say Brokaw
made unwanted sexual advances the letter
reads in part quote he has given each of
us opportunities for advancement and
championed our successes throughout our
careers
it comes as Brokaw attempts to tell his
side of the story and a Warner reports I
was groped and assaulted by Tom Brokaw
in interviews with Variety magazine and
the Washington Post
former NBC News correspondent Linda
Wester described two unwanted advances
from Tom Brokaw in the mid-1990s
including one in which she says he
invited himself into her hotel room he
leans over with his index finger and
puts it on my mouth to silence me and
says this is our compact and at that
point you took the same hand reach
behind my head and tried to force me to
kiss him in a letter to colleagues
published by several news organizations
Brokaw pushed back hard saying Wester
Zelig ations were akin to a drive-by
shooting I was ambushed and then perp
walked he said taken to the guillotine
and stripped of any honor and
achievement I had earned in more than a
half century of journalism and
citizenship Brokaw said it was Wester
who invited him to her New York hotel
room I should not have gone he said but
I emphatically did not verbally and
physically attack her back then had she
reported something like this I don't
think anyone would have blinked I think
it's a different time Washington Post
reporter Sarah Ellison says a second
unnamed NBC employee described another
incident around the same time she told
the post Brokaw put her hands against
his chest pulled her closer then invited
her to later come to his office Brokaw
told the post no such incident happened
the post said neither woman reported the
allegations to NBC at the time these new
sexual harassment complaints are the
latest against high-profile media
figures including
former CBS this morning co-host Charlie
Rhodes fired by CBS in November people
are afraid to report on people in power
they're afraid they won't be believed
and they're afraid that there will be
some kind of retaliation for CBS this
morning Saturday and a Werner New York